today is april 15th which typically is
tax day but the deadline was pushed back
for a lot of people because of the
pandemic the irs given extra time to
file your federal taxes
they're now due on may 17th however the
delay isn't for everyone
if you're a freelancer gig worker
self-employed or small
business owner you still must make your
estimated payments
if you are not make sure to ask your tax
preparer or check
irs.gov to see if you qualify
now again today is still a crucial
deadline for some taxpayers
like those gig workers independent
contractors sole proprietors
and other self-employed individuals
though the irs postponed the income tax
filing date
it kept the 2021 estimated payment
schedule intact
which means june 15th rather today june
15th in addition to september 15th
there's a quiz later
and january 18th the estimated payments
still need to be made
for those individuals if you're not sure
about your status
check with your tax preparer irs.gov to
see if you qualify we're hammering home
a little double info there